come and get it  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  my friend  your desire  is the bringer of life  the gift of the goddess  you're a little more important than my  sword  [Music]  but just a little a soldier trademark oh  you  [Music]  color of the sky right but  not scary at all  good news song  me and  cloud  it means angel  has betrayed us as well  angel wouldn't betray us never  if people had wings they'd be monsters  wings  they don't symbolize monsters  your glory should have been mine  how petty  in hindsight perhaps what the hell did  you do here deal  well look who's here  depending on what happens  i may abandon shinra angels dream of one  thing  please tell me  to be human  legends shall speak  of sacrifice  at world's end  you